what what this looks so uncomfortable
but it's so so good
this is my fashion I can't do a full
wave fashion a train fitted beaded tell
me about this look I'm really scared I'm
gonna trip on the train as I come out to
a presented award I hope you do yeah
it's gonna be great yeah yeah it'll be
great on brand for you it'll be super
cute it'll be a great moment yeah
congratulations on everything what a
year what a breakout moment when are we
getting the sequel I don't know all I do
know is that there is there is for sure
a sequel when I don't know have you
signed on yeah yeah I mean as far as I
know yeah have you seen a script have
not seen a script yet but I hear it's in
the works
you're gonna be very busy let's talk
about your long list of jobs Kevin Hart
in the rock Jumanji yes yes that's
happening that's how that's gonna happen
very very excited just about getting in
the middle of that bromance I don't they
are and they have a big relationship you
know no I definitely know that I think
that mine will just run parallel to
theirs I don't think that I'll be you
know get in the middle yeah but they
have a very adorable bromance yes they
do you could like kind of yeah we'll try
to like stir it up a little bit try to
try to act like a bro you know like what
sequel do you think will get first crazy
rich or oceans man either I don't know
we just wanna know what your plans oh no
I well okay I'll tell you this you will
get a crazier dejan sequel and I'll tell
you that's all the ladies would love to
do in oceans name sequel I mean I'm
totally down for it and I think they
would be they would be too so Sarah
Paulson and she says she wants Bette
Midler or Emma Thompson to join the crew
oh I would love some Bette Midler action
oh my god wind beneath my wings while
I'm criminal no she is the wind beneath
my wings that's that's who she is yeah I
wish she was here I want to talk a
little more about your fashion who made
this dress
Mimi plage how did you pick it is it
comfortable
what's the secret we don't know what are
you gonna eat when you get out of it oh
my god Taco Bell
and yeah I mean like you know there's a
joking raiser dajun's that says like
like red is a good luck color and when I
was when I first saw this dress it just
seemed like a very perfect celebration
of what we're doing here tonight yeah
how cool is it to be nominated you guys
got the critics now the people now the
fellow actor yeah I mean that's amazing
man so because you were recognized by
your peers it is truly a it's a more
validating feeling I think and yeah I
mean it's so excited my first time here
I can't believe it's real I can't
believe that there's a gold guy over
there
that's awesome yeah there's Lady Gaga
and there's McCarthy and that was really
got to do Jones in the blue she was yeah
wow that was cool dude I just saw Kyle
Jones that's awesome yeah thanks lady
question train okay so we've been asking
people there's a train of questions from
other actors okay so your question from
Chris Sullivan of this is us is is there
a personal item you bring to these
events to ground you of Costco chicken I
try to stuff it in my clutch I fold her
up yeah you just told me she didn't
bring any sandwiches this time oh my god
I know you gotta be out about the
sandwiches yeah
[Music]